russia's forests are burning
one and a half million hectares in the
worst hit region of yakutia
after another exceptionally hot and dry
summer
we're out with pavel petrov who's
coordinating the response around
yakutiya's badly hit
gorney district
speeding along freshly dug trenches
which are meant to keep them at bay
where there's smoke there's fire the
forest smoldering a little further along
the trenches
most wildfires start from a lightning
strike during a dry thunderstorm
but these fires are set by the
firefighters to clear through the dead
wood
and undergrowth so that when the real
big wildfire comes it's got nothing to
burn on
it's literally fighting fire with fire
andre piston who's been sent in to help
from the west of siberia shows
us proudly what his men were dealing
with the day before
sergey to the right of me is the only
professional firefighter in this truck
all of them are vaccinated by the way
you're not allowed to fight the fires
unless you've had the jab were you
working on this yesterday
and was it was it scary
they send up a drone to look for the
fires but also to work out where to set
up camp next it needs to be near a water
source in case the fires come close
and they need a plan b
each fire needs its own individual
strategy and with so many burning across
siberia
it's only those the firefighters can
even reach that they tackle
that means that many burn unchecked
emitting huge amounts of carbon into the
atmosphere as they do
and they're burning on permafrost which
as it thaws emits greenhouse gases too
and this is just in russia there are
wildfires raging across the us
and canada too catastrophic floods in
europe
a month of extreme weather events across
the globe
it's been a long hard month for pablo
patrol
[Music]
museum
siberians have always had to deal with
the most extreme temperatures on earth
now as these wildfires increase in
intensity
they are also bearing the brunt of our
changing climate
dynamagne sky news in gorny siberia